die bilder macht man ein foto von mir ja
mach ich da ich bin doch schon jede
menge kommen ja noch mal schneller
erfolg haben aber mein name ist luca
meine damen und herren ihr seht es
bereits im titel eingeblendet google
maps das ist der vatikanstaat genau ich
habe mir nehme ich gedacht ich war noch
nie in rom beziehungsweise hier im
vatikan und habe mir gedacht hat würde
ich schon immer gerne hin reisen aber
ich hab kein bock dahin zu reisen
deswegen erkunden wir heute das mit
google maps also es geht direkt los hier
wir befinden uns beim piazza san pietro
gerade hier vorne sind einfach ein paar
beine
sieht nicht so gesund aus auf jeden fall
sehen wir hier schon diesem piazza san
pietro ist von pietro lombardi der
palast auf jeden fall können uns jetzt
mal so ein bisschen rum bewegen in rom
mit google street view hallo
dass irgendwas gelbes auf seiner hose
raushängen das ist gerade das geile hier
an und zwar ich glaube ich fahren die
falsche richtung versteht ein an der
wand kokain
das habe ich mir hier nichts mit zu tun
haben jetzt verkaufst du dass dir die
rentner wahrscheinlich auch auf der
strecke schon seine hand so aus um bei
der linken ist die hand oder zensiert
also da würde ich sagen haben wir direkt
wieder ab freunde da wirklich eine frau
vom auto überfahren ganz skurrile ecke
hier ich würde sagen wir gehen mal ein
anderes viertel das ist ja das tolle an
google street view da kann es einfach
sagen hey gefällt mir nicht ich die mal
so ein bisschen weiter hier vorne ist
ein kind das
vom teufel besessen ist also keine
ahnung was hier im vatikanstaat so
wirklich abgeht
hier ist irgendwie auch im sitzen hier
so viele menschen wahrscheinlich weil
der sitzgelegenheiten sind oder luca wir
fahren hier einfach mal mit unserer
google street view kann so ein bisschen
langsam mein gott das ist ja das ist ja
wunderschön hier
da sieht man seinen pro also ich wusste
nicht dass es hier so schön ist ich
dachte der vatikanstaat das wären
willkommen auch mit ihnen
also sorry und was machen die wegen
hochwassers ist alter sind überschwemmt
also ich wusste ja nicht dass das hier
so schön ist
das ist nämlich genau das ding was ich
mir bei diesem video gedacht habe
beziehungsweise bei dieser serie
falls ihr bock drauf habe dass das
normal mache dann hat man like da wir
fahren mit unserer google street view
car also ein bisschen durch die gegend
können uns alles hier so ein bisschen
anschauen und auch timo bella vita push
up bhs soll es auch geben ihr könnt
jetzt ganz einfach einen kommentar hier
unter das video schreiben mit einer
anderen stadt und in der nächsten folge
würde ich mir dann die stadt mal
anschauen
aber jetzt schauen wir uns erstmal rom
an was machst du hier kksv bürger steigt
also ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wo
ich jetzt gerade rumfahren
ach guck mal hier der mine content sei
was von müllwagen ich weiß wirklich
nicht wo wir hier gerade eine snackbar
und stellt euch mal vor ihr hättet so
was in eurem ankleidezimmer dass jetzt
eine ganz lustige funktion da kann's
nämlich einfach raussuchen und dann
können wir jetzt hier irgendwo hingehen
haben wir nicht irgendwo das kolosseum
da ist es das kolosseum da war ich auch
nie eher misstrauisch wenn ich noch nie
in rom war das heißt wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal hier eine seitenstraße und
sehen schon
das kolosseum ist direkt unter den
bäumen dies aber gar kein problem denn
wir sind ja google maps und können uns
ja da
dass er komplett beschützen also sieht
schon echt cool aus und man sieht ja
auch hier habt ihr alle sonnenhüte auf
war halt überall schon ein erstes team
street damals aber naja gut okay das ist
ein bisschen so aussieht der
triumphbogen tatsächlich in nähe
er sieht gar nicht der triumphbogen hat
ja mit ja vier so teile
daran merkt man wie toll ich im
geschichtsunterricht aufgepasst habe ich
ja auch egal freunde ich will auf jeden
fall ins kolosseum rein das heißt ich
jetzt mal hierhin und
denn angeblich im kolosseum drin aber
irgendwie auch nicht ein paar sekunden
später das ist das kolosseum freunde
hier wohl
einfach mal nur ein oberkörper haben
hier wurden früher auf jeden fall die
ganzen krassen kämpfe ausgetragen etc
therapie
die sketch
hier macht irgendwie bilder sie ist weil
man vertreten die handys zweimal
vertreten die haben auch übels geile
slippers an also echt hammer geil
es sieht so aus wie der junge zu groß
für diese kinder ding ist aber hey ich
bin ganz ehrlich ich habe mich auch so
lange es gegen in einem kinderwagen
transportieren lassen
halt so entspannt wie jetzt einfach rum
geschoben ein sehr sehr mysteriöser ort
auf jeden fall diese
warum
ist es hier ist es nicht
das loch das war auf jeden fall das
kolosseum was für uns hier mal
angeschaut haben wirklich eine sehr sehr
sehr sehr geile stadt will ich auf jeden
fall noch mal hin
ich würde allerdings sagen dass wir uns
jetzt nochmal den kölner dom anschauen
also hier ist halt köln und hier fordere
müsste der dom irgendwo sein genau hier
vorne ist das heißt ich hab mal dass
manager die hin und teilnehmer hier hin
und sehen schon ach du heilige scheiße
da war karneval ok das ist so wahnsinn
in köln wie viel einfach in dieser
kapstadt da los ist hier oben haben auf
jeden fall den kölner dom der wird gar
nicht so groß wie ein echtes 89
aber okay gut machst du mal weiter
du hast
genauso hält man regenschirm
wahrscheinlich würde einfach ein paar
kamelle fangen
der schläft glaube ich gerade im stand
auf jeden fall ist dass der karneval am
kölner dom tatsächlich ich weiß gar
nicht genau ich will ich will ich wollte
eigentlich den dom zeigen kann ich hier
nicht irgendwo noch innerhalb von einer
sekunde ist karneval wieder vorbei gott
oh gott ist das hier alles so beschissen
aus der ganze platz wird komplett neu
gemacht
der kölner dom ist glaube ich wenn man
hier
steakhouse ja das ist das kölner
wahrzeichen von hier finde ich das immer
ganz schön da sieht man dann
jan o
ja ich finde hier sieht eigentlich ganz
schön aus
hi
der guckt grimmig also bei google maps
ist echt so einiges vertreten deswegen
meine damen und herren wenn ihr wollt
dass ich mich auch mal eure stadt die
ihr gerne sehen würde wie ich sie sehe
schreibt mir gerne unten in die
kommentare last leichter wenn euch meine
google maps rundlauf kg hier gefallen
hat und sonst
[Musik]